I went through basic SEAL training and
there and you get to eat actually a lot
most of the time you're getting three
meals a day and usually one or two of
them are in a chow hall where it's
basically all you can eat and I always
feel you know the Rangers that get one
MRE a day for whatever that is you know
85 days and you know those guys always
lose 20 to 15 20 25 pounds I gained I
gained 11 pounds going through Seal
training well yeah I went from 174 to
185. and that's working out however long
you're working out you know doing a ton
of physical activity but I was just
eating a ton and you could get like get
done at night I would be ordering pizza
at 10 o'clock or 11 o'clock at night I'd
order pizza Domino's would deliver we
would eat pizza just about well we eat a
pizza on a lot of nights so we're
getting a lot of calories but I always
found that the the Army has a little bit
more stringent about what they're gonna
let you eat in their special forces
schools